Rosie is in Oregon Rosie welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show your question for Ken
and I I thanks for having me
so my husband is self-employed through
both construction and commercial fishing
and then he goes up to Alaska every
summer for about six to eight weeks and
we're approaching the time that we
usually spend some money on the season
and with insurance and permits and
sending food and stuff up there but with
all that's going on in the world we're
just trying to figure out what we should
weigh in deciding whether or not he'll
be going this year what kind of cost are
you talking about what's the number so
it's about a fifteen to seventeen
thousand permanent lease for the boat a
fishing leasing and then and about I
don't know three to five thousand
dollars on supplies like food tools and
etc because where he is it's so remote
that everything is very expensive so
what is he what is he a net on a typical
season what see net profit last year
well over the last five years has been
very steady
last year specifically we netted fifty
five thousand okay so why would he not
be able to do that again all of the
tethers up there are just sort of
sending out the message of you know we
don't know what this is going to look
like
Alaska's regulating you know when you
fly in go out so you have to quarantine
for 14 days almost all of the employees
at the canneries have to fly there
because everybody travels there to work
the summer window again
only your June not fly it and then it's
still early to tell but offices eyes and
many yeah and so you would have to spend
$15,000
to be ready to go in June you would have
to probably spend closer to 20 um
because the permit that we released
rather than buy it to buy a permit is
around $200,000 right now
and so we just pay year by year too so
let's say you took the permit so you
took the permit out and the whole place
is shut down in June you can't go uh-huh
you had the I assume you paid cash for
the permit right we pay cash for all of
you
yeah so it would just be down the toilet
they'd be really painful but it wouldn't
break you you just had to go back to
work where you're stateside right you
lose you lose 1520 thousand bucks and
you go back to work right in cash yeah
yeah okay so what price you know what
you've got to ask yourself is what you
think the probability is by June Alaska
is opening up mm-hmm and I don't know
the answer to that I never dreamed we'd
be that we'd have an entire country
sitting in their homes I think I could
not fathom that that would ever happen
mm-hmm I just weeks ago I couldn't
fathom that it was going to happen so I
can't fathom that by June that this
economy is not back up and running and
that we have moved on for God's sakes
but I can't fathom it but that doesn't
mean it won't happen so you've just got
to ask yourself what probability is this
and can you emotionally handle and
financially handle losing that money on
your worst case scenario I I personally
would be pretty sure enough that I that
we were gonna go in June that we would
go in June okay
I mean I would drop the money right now
I wouldn't think anything about it cuz I
cannot fathom that we won't be a back up
and running but I can't guarantee that
to you you know what I'm saying so you
just gotta gotta walk through it that
way in your mind and decide you know
which direction you want to go yeah
because you gotta weigh the cost so
you're gonna lose the 55 if you don't go
or not so how much do they rely on the
55 if that's the average that's what she
said the average net has been over the
last few years so how much do you rely
on that 55 because if
you lose the 20 in cash and you don't
get the 55 got away that so maybe you
hold on to the 20 cash and you say we're
gonna live to fight next year you know
or do you say let me get up there now on
touch so you know I see thinking about
could I get to Alaska now you know or is
he doing construction on their own
everything shut down now yeah 14 day
quarantine she says that I gotta tell
you it races like it's a foreign country
it's crazy
I don't know here's the problem with
this whole thing okay that is a
microcosm and you multiply that times
millions of that decision right there
that's a she doesn't spend the 15,000
the guy that holds the lease up there is
out that money that's exactly is he
caught his economy is hurt the food she
would have bought up there yeah that's
the those people have lost their money
by the way not as many fish are caught
so now there's a shortage on fish so the
price goes up on fish a dime of next
year yeah and so you just multiply this
out in every industry in America this
it's not only the two weeks we can shut
down to make sure we kill the Toronto
virus it's you're now making decisions
all the way into the summer yeah all the
way in the May June July and people are
changing you know you know we're working
with Marriott on some of our events and
they just closed all of their hotels
yeah through April you're talking about
a charming new April earthquake not a
ripple they get it just shakes some
people yeah it's that this is real you
guys it's real the I think the people
that were honestly very intellectually
engaged in the curve and the geometric
progression of the virus and the fear
that they felt associated with that
caused them to not even consider you
know the misery index of what is going
to happen to people's lives on the
economic side well I certainly right the
trade-off is greater than any of them
understood well we've got to be studying
the the mortality rate and we've also
got to look at if it's overwhelming
health care systems and let's help the
healthcare systems yeah I don't only
write it down only buddy
I don't even buy loser job I don't
anybody lose their whole way of you know
she's almost $55,000 if she doesn't do
this yeah and to your point that has an
economic impact on the other it's a
ripple effect yeah you know it's um
they're really that stuff really does
work that way there really is a
trickle-down and that makes people
cringe because they don't like
trickle-down if they're liberals but
it's not really there truly is if I
don't buy food for our cafeteria here
because our team is not here the people
that make that food don't have jobs well
a large portion of the 3.3 million or
3.2 million unemployment cases come from
people staying home not going to
restaurants not going to hotels not
going on vacation it's real and at some
point the nation's governors they
ultimately are the chief executive
officers of their states this isn't a
political statement this is an economic
statement at some point the American
people and the governors of these states
are gonna have to say what do we do to
take care of the health side of this
thing but also get people back in the
economy and working now it's I'm not
saying it's easy I don't think people I
do not think the medical people and the
people coming at it from that lens had
any grasp of how much misery they were
gonna cost with this no I don't think
they in any crash no I don't think they
would have done it if they have well
they probably would have but well I mean
they're coming at it from a medical
standpoint they're going to look we're
trying to save lives when we get that
but we've got you know we are an
intricate world and when you have a
health crisis like this you've also got
to have the ability for the economies to
work folks these governments around and
around the world can't just keep bailing
it out in to your point you said earlier
in the program today appreciate the two
trillion dollar package but you've got a
20 trillion dollar GDP so this isn't
going to fix everything and by the way
Congress has the House of Representative
representatives haven't even passed it
yet so you know this is a complex time
that requires difficult leadership